hello everyone and welcome to another
game from defeated World Cup 2019 it's a
Game two of the match earlier as a
future versus ding leerin and due to
class / games they played were drawn
we've already shown a game one of the
rapid section being wanted game it was
extremely hard game ding you know I
really had to grind it out in the end
game eventually he won't and now Ally
Reza has to win this otherwise he is out
of the video World Cup so you have the
white pieces against ding what do you
play Reza opens with Knight to f3 at the
reti opening with d5 binding III Knight
to f6 and now c4 so waiting with d4 with
ecigs biding and Knight to c3 still
keeping the options of d4 open and be
succeeding now prefers the V and cut off
his light square bishop with Queen to a4
check already a very peculiar position
there are only two games that have
reached this position Bishop to d7 was
played and the Knight to d7 but C sinks
c6 the move ding place is a new move and
it's already as of move 5 that we have a
completely new game which is no wonder
as early as I was trying to you know
really create some craziness that
allowed him for some winning chances
probably he thought if ding wasn't you
know if didn't couldn't beat me well
almost from the Queen's Gambit the
client and probably I should stay away
from that but okay Bishop to e2
preparing the castle and the Bishop to
d6 biding just nicely developing with d3
and now castles biding and E for now
with D captures on e4 d captures on e4
and Queen to c7 and here already an
interesting move c5 here ollie Reza
wants ding to play Bishop captures on c5
to get a 5 in to kind of create create
some imbalances and the position gets
the e4 square for his Knight perhaps
create some attacking chances maybe the
Queen can come to G for the knight could
maybe come to e4 maybe to f6 later who
knows but ding isn't interested in that
ding is well he already won one game
he's not interested
looking for adventure he plays beat that
person c5 he doesn't mind
messing up his pawn structure on the
queenside a little bit with castles by
OSHA and the now comes Knight B to d7 G
3 now the knight can move the h2 pawn
will not be under attack and Knight the
e5 offering more trades Alireza declines
this with knife to d2 preparing f4 to
start well his advancements on the King
side and Bishop back to e7 with f4 as
planned and night a 37 now and the g4
creating an all-out pawn storm on the
Kings side he's well he has to go all-in
with rook to b8 king is ready for g5 so
now that's nice to EA displayed the rook
will not be stuck on f8 we have g5
pushing the knight back nice th and now
even h4 and okay ding doesn't seem to be
all that all that worried about what's
happening on the Kings side he plays a5
he wants to develop his light square
Bishop with E 5 now and now as ollie
Reza put all of his pawns here on dark
squares ding prevents in any more
pushing of the pawns with g6
Knight d2 e for going for night sorry
that's a sea knight Knight beta e for
going after the f6 square and the now
comes the night to Jeep knife to g7 well
d f6 square is a very nice word for the
white knight but the f5 square is an
excellent outpost for dings night so he
plays it with Knight to f6 check and
here we have Bishop captures on f6 we
have G captures on f6 attacking the
knight and the night finally finds his
place here on the f5 Square and h5
continuing to push on the King side
really to bust open the position and
here
ding had the very interesting
opportunity of playing Knight captures
on e5 it's a nice idea but for a rapid
game he's up one point no no reason to
get crazy but it's a very interesting
idea Knight captures and after pawn
captures you go roopd for attacking the
Queen and once the Queen retreats and
now you go bush of chaos or the Queen
captures on e5 and you have just well
yeah
excellent compensation for your
sacrifice piece the two pawns the king
is a well wide open here probably
something they would play in a class 4
game but here he goes c4 he decides to
give back the pawn to get the c5 square
for his Knight and then if white is not
interested in grabbing on c4 then he can
also get the Knights to d3 this is his
plan with H captures on g6 first by
Ferrara H captures on g6 and now Queen
back to C to the Queen now has to go
back here so here you're kind of hoping
to get for example the Queen and the
rook on the H file maybe maybe try and
get some action over there but the black
also has his say in this with Queen to
b6 width check and here King to h8 is a
mandatory move but a laser plays rook to
f2 and this could become a problem for
him dingos nice to see 5 this Knight is
now coming to d3 and it's well if you
don't eliminate the c4 pawn then the
knight is staying on d3 because once you
capture the dink would get a very strong
past D pawn so Bishop captures on c3 and
now Bishop to e6 getting rid of the
bishop as the bishop guards the d3
square with Bishop captures rook
captures and now King to g2 Araiza
realizes that this was no place for the
rook or the King to be on and now
finally nice to d3 from ding the rook is
under attack the bishop is under attack
so obviously you have to move it rook to
F 1 and here Bing says okay I'm gonna
play rook a7 go over to d7w works on the
d file and this should be good for me
but here ding misses a very nice
tactical shot so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this well idea
being missed maybe he didn't miss it
maybe she he just didn't feel like
playing it as he it's a rapid game and
he really needs to to go safe about it
but yeah for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent finder of nice tactical shots
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show Knight captures on c1 the
point is you cannot capture with either
of the rooks because 93 check will pick
up the Queen a very nice fork is working
so you have to play Queen captures on c1
and now not even night
III check the window rook immediately
first you go rook d3 and now you have
the thread of night III check the route
can come to g3 with check and why
doesn't really have any moves you can't
move the Queen out or why screen-capture
son b2 comes with check it's just
disgusting position for white but okay
being found a different idea she wants
to go rook to develop rooks
Knight to e4 and now rook 87 and here
Quinta Ito by ferocious but now rook the
d4 just grabbing more space putting
pressure on the f4 point if the knife
from e4 moves but Knight to d6 was
actually a good try for example if
Knight captures pawn captures now you
cannot capture for example with this
rook because of Bishop to e3 but you
could capture with this rook however at
least white would get some development
in the fellowship played Bishop to d2
instead and now Dean just goes in with
the Queen we have Queen captures and b2
looks to be one attacking the Queen
and now well Deb everything wins in this
position for the anything found the well
one of the nicer forcing moves he played
rook captures on e4 Knight f4 check also
wins if you want to check that out but
rook captures I need for just offering a
rook for for two pieces and the check
for also decided you know let's play
Queen captures on d3 hopefully we can
trade Queens you know you capture this
I'll capture that but ding just played
Queen captures and e2 with check and it
was in this position unmoved 34 that
holidays a furor resigned the game and
with this he is out of the feed a World
Cup 2019 he resigned because after the
trade here sorry after the trade you are
just down a whole piece and you're not
you you're not in a great position you
have no compensation whatever you are
very quickly getting made it yeah
ELISA is out of the tournament it was a
tough break for him you know playing
such excellent chess and then having to
face things so early on but you know you
would face him someday but okay if you
faced him in the finals it doesn't
really matter because even if you don't
win the World Cup you still go get a
spot in the candidate so maybe that was
a better scenario for him but you never
should look at things like that so an
excellent run by him and the ending
advances into the next round of the fede
World Cup awaiting his next victim so
that's that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
both of these games are you know choices
by me III decide to show them as early
as is a very exciting young player and
being is just the top seed a monster so
I thought you'd enjoy both of these
games but feel free to suggest any other
game I will check them out and we're
definitely gonna show at least one more
game from the tiebreaks to also check
out the standings and you know who keep
to out who who advanced and so on sure I
would like to thank Alex lahrman for a
contributor to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can checked all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the World Cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and and so on we will have
our conclusion of the cup of Wonka saga
do not worry about that so thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day